THEY LOOK PRETTY GOOD.
- OH, YEAH, I DID.
I HAD ONE OF THE CHERRY ONES.
- OH.
- SO GOOD.
- THEY LOOK PRETTY--PRETTY GOOD.
- YEAH, GO FOR IT.
- I'VE ALWAYS
HAD A WEIGHT PROBLEM.
MY DOCTORS SAY THAT
IT'S BECAUSE I EAT TOO MUCH,
BUT WHO KNOWS, RIGHT?
- YEAH.
BUT HEY, YOU KNOW, IT IS NEVER
TOO LATE TO CHANGE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO TELL YOURSELF
YOU'RE WORTH
both: $1 MILLION.
- YOU'VE GOT IT.
- [laughs]
HEY.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR
MY MILLION-DOLLAR IDEA?
- SURE, YEAH.
I'M SURE IT'S GREAT.
- OKAY.
- OH, YEAH.
[chuckles]
- IT'S A MUZZLE...
- MM-HMM.
- THAT WORKS ON A TIME LOCK
SO THAT YOU CAN'T EAT
BETWEEN MEALS.
- OH, OKAY.
SO IT'S FOR PEOPLE?
- UH-HUH.
- IT'S A MUZZLE FOR PEOPLE?
- YEAH.
- AND IT, LIKE, COVERS UP
YOUR MOUTH ALL DAY LONG,
EXCEPT FOR--
- EXCEPT FOR MEALTIME.
- AND THE REST
OF THE TIME OF THE DAY,
YOUR MOUTH IS COVERED OVER
BY THIS--
BY A MUZZLE?
- YOU HATE IT?
- WHO CARES WHAT I THINK?
THE IMPORTANT THING
IS THAT YOU KNOW
THAT YOU ARE WORTH $1 MILLION.
- OH, YEAH.
- I KNOW I DO.
- YEAH.
- I'M WORTH $1 MILLION.
- $1 MILLION.
- NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
[laughs]
- COOL.
- ALL RIGHT.
- $1 MILLION.
- SEE YOU OUT THERE
ON THOSE COALS, OKAY?
- OKAY.
- NOW, I WANT ALL OF YOU
TO CLOSE YOUR EYES.
THERE'S ONE THING
EACH OF YOU BROUGHT HERE TODAY--
YOUR MILLION-DOLLAR IDEA.
THIS IS WHAT
YOU'RE GONNA SHOUT OUT
AS YOU WALK
ACROSS THOSE HOT COALS.
- EXCUSE ME.
WERE WE SUPPOSED TO COME HERE
WITH A MILLION-DOLLAR IDEA
ALREADY IN MIND?
- YEAH.
IT'S--IT'S THE HEART
OF "WEALTHNASTICS."
- THIS IDEA--
- OH, GOD.
OKAY.
LUCILLE HAD GIVEN ME A PACKET OF
INFORMATION ABOUT THIS SEMINAR
BUT DID NOT INSIST
THAT I READ IT.
HER NEGLIGENCE PUT ME
IN A TERRIBLE POSITION.
JUST THINK OF IT, JUST THINK
OF IT, JUST THINK OF IT.
JUST SAY IT.
JUST SAY--JUST SAY ONE THING.
I--A TOILET
THAT CAN FLUSH ITSELF
OR A TOILET--A TOILET
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SIT ON.
OR A BATHROOM--WHY--